obviously just had an incredible exhibit
proof of how intensely tied together
national economies are in this
globalized world of ours so now we find
even emerging economies that haven't
invested in subprime mortgages are
getting hammered and so clearly a
globalization is not a thing that one
could talk about being for or against a
wishing to have more or less it is just
it's the air we breathe it's the fact of
our life and so the question is how can
this be used as a positive as opposed to
as a negative and I think trade is a key
example because when we talk about
needing to help impoverished countries
for example you know we should give them
more aid and so forth and I think if we
can use the aid wisely that's right but
in general those numbers are small
compared to the kind of revenue that
these countries can be receiving in a
freer trade system and so the failure of
all the major trading nations of the
world to arrive at some regime and what
was called the Doha round some regime of
global free trade which would have among
other things produce tremendous benefits
for impoverished countries hoping to
penetrate the markets of more developed
countries that's a disaster that's
really a disaster and it is fair to ask
of Obama who has been who is like any
Democrat needs to court unions and
others who are very skeptical about free
trade it's fair to ask of Obama whether
he is really going to commit himself to
the kind of global trading regime which
will bring real benefits to impoverished
nations especially if it means telling
some American farmers we
keep giving you these subsidies
you